There are some really interesting posts on
the David Pakman show sub Reddit that I wanted
to call your attention to this morning.
Of course, you can join the discussion at
David Pakman dot com slash r e d d i t. We
now have a nearly 23000, if you can imagine
it. I remember when the sub Reddit was teeny
tiny. We now have almost 23000 of our viewers
and listeners participating there. Find it
at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit. A user
named Texas, Mekhi posted. Call me an optimist,
but I think David is wrong about the number
of Trump lists in the country.
I've heard him say that even if Biden wins,
this country will still need to grapple with
60 million Trump ists who voted for him. I
won't dispute that Trump's will be a problem
for this country long after Trump is out of
office. However, I don't believe that even
most Republican voters are Trump's. I think
we underestimate the number of people who
just vote for whoever has a big R next to
their name on the ballot and move on with
their lives. They're not diehards. They're
loyal voters who don't really care about policy.
They couldn't tell you what Trump has done
well or poorly. They couldn't tell you how
Biden differs from Trump in any meaningful
way. They just vote the party line every four
years.
I'm not saying the Trump best ideology isn't
something to be taken as a serious threat.
I only mean that I think it's a smaller sect
within the party. Well, you know that oftentimes
when we talk about radical Islam, you will
hear these sort of concentric circles of nominal,
the nominal Muslim world, which is a billion
people. And then within that, these subsequently
smaller and smaller groups. And you could
do this for any population. You could do it
with Christian extremists. You could do it
with Jewish extremists, these smaller and
smaller circles. You're right that if you
start with 65 million people who might vote
for Donald Trump in November, not all 65 are
the problematic radical Trump lists, that's
for sure. But certainly the 65 million are
people who decided to go along with it regardless.
And that's bad enough in a lot of ways. You
can then look at smaller numbers.
So of the 65 million, you have some portion
who almost voted for Biden but went with the
Republican because of their historically Republican,
they might be the least offensive of the group.
Then you've got people who actually like what
Donald Trump presents in terms of what he
says he will do policy wise, but also more
his idea of constantly trying to trigger the
left than you like, that that might be, you
know, 80 percent and then you've got these
concentric circles. That's true. The problem
is that when we think about the future of
the country, it is worse if you are a diehard
Trump list than just a lifelong Republican
Republican who checks the box for Republicans.
That's true, but it's still a total of 65
million people who voted for it. And if given
the opportunity, might vote for it again.
So while you're right, that 65 million is
not the number of, you know, the crazy people
with the guns that we're seeing protests.
That's true. Sixty five million is still the
number of people who have given the opportunity
would probably do it again. And that's why
it's extraordinarily dangerous. Another post
from a user on the sub Reddit posted an article
about doctors who are alarmed that the U.S.
FDA is floating emergency use of a corona
virus vaccine, potentially bypassing some
of the trials. I predicted that this was going
to happen. I told you guys months ago that
it was going to happen. I wasn't the only
person saying it. It's not a pat on the back.
It's that it was so obvious that this was
going to happen. And, yes, even people who
are in favor of vaccines are writing to me,
worried that using emergency use authorization
mechanisms to push a vaccine out for likely
political benefit by Donald Trump is something
we should be concerned about. And that's what
I'm going to talk about next. I'm glad that
it's on people's radars. Remember, you can
join the discussion on the sub it at David
Pakman dot com slash r
e
d DHT.